لقد أخذنا
الفيروس من المرضى بعد أن اضطررنا إلى
تنقية الفيروس ،
فإن السباق للحصول على لقاح لم يكن
شرسًا في
جميع أنحاء العالم
، يجري العمل على 166 لقاحًا محتملاً لفيروس covid19 مثل
لقاح فالينيفا هنا في غرب فرنسا
، وقد باعت الشركة الأوروبية للأدوية
60 مليون جرعة للتو  من
لقاحها المستقبلي المحتمل
للمملكة المتحدة ، الهدف هو
توفير
60 مليون جرعة بنهاية عام 2021 وبعد
زيادة
السعة أيضًا تأمل val neva
أن تكون جاهزة للتجارب السريرية بحلول
نهاية هذا العام
24 شركة أخرى تعمل على تطوير  اللقاحات
في تلك المرحلة بالفعل ، وفي الوقت الحالي ، تقوم
العديد من الحكومات بالتحوط من رهاناتها
، وتدرك جميع الحكومات تمامًا أن الطلب المسبق
الذي تم تمريره اليوم في خطر تام ،
حيث تضع في نهاية المطاف خمسة
إلى عشرة طلبات مسبقة على برامج
مختلفة وهم يعرفون ذلك في  النهاية على
الأرجح ستنجح ثلاثة فقط
وهذا هو السبب في أن الصفقة البريطانية مع
Valeneva تأتي كجزء من اتفاقية أوسع
مع شركات أخرى  es
في يوليو ، اختارت المملكة المتحدة عدم
الانضمام إلى تحالف لقاحات الاتحاد الأوروبي
، تم إنشاؤه من قبل أربع
دول أوروبية للتعويض عن نقص
التنسيق على مستوى الاتحاد
الأوروبي ، تواصل المفاوضات الأوروبية مع
Valeneva فينا.
هو أنه إذا كان بإمكاننا الحصول على بادا مركزية واحدة
، فلنفترض أنها ستجعلها
في المرة القادمة أكثر
فاعلية من حيث التعامل مع هذا
النوع من المرض
، توصل التحالف الأوروبي القوي بين الدول الأربع الآن إلى
صفقة واحدة مقابل 400000 لقاح مع
أسترازينيكا
ولكن  لم تقم بعد ببناء نوع الملف الذي
أعلنت
عنه المملكة المتحدة يوم الإثنين ،
ولن تذهب لقاحات فالينيفا الأولى الآن إلى
البلدان الأوروبية
ولكن إلى المملكة المتحدة شريكها السابق في الاتحاد الأوروبي
ميليسا بيل سي إن باريس